herr trittin was ist mit der
pendlerpauschale stellen sie sich vor
wir sitzen jetzt hier in ihrer
verhandlungsgruppe und sie stellen sich
mal vor der an die steuer ist nicht bei
der csu sondern vielleicht bei der fdp
und sie verhandeln jetzt mit ihm her
über die pendlerpauschale was wäre denn
da ihr vorschlag
sei eine antwort auf das gegeben was die
möglicherweise überraschen würde ich
finde die idee die in frankreich
stattgefunden hat
die haben gesagt wir machen da
einmalzahlung aber der grund an idee
dies richtig wir haben denjenigen
die sich das aufgrund ihrer anfangs
situation nicht mehr leisten können
einen zuschuss es war ein grund weswegen
ich gesagt habe im deutschen system
wir machen das nicht einmal ich wir
machen das über das wohngeld da kommt
dann wahrscheinlich für viele über das
jahr gerechnet mehr als 100 euro aus und
wie machen wir es dadurch dass wir das
feuer für ein existenzminimum und die
grundsicherung anheben das führt dann in
der tat dazu dass diejenigen die
aufgrund gestiegener
energiepreise in eine schwierige
situation kommen us-geführten ist das
denn die energie check oder wie muss man
sich das vorstellen nein wir machen ja
schlicht und der graf sang der höhe des
einkommens abhängig wie die franzosen
das auch gemacht haben und ich halte das
auch für richtig und für zielgenau ja
ein weiteres hinzufügen
wir waren immer der auffassung dass man
kontinuierliche steigerung des co2
freies machen muss uns in
übereinstimmung mit der csu ich könnte
ihnen das zitat von herrn dobrindt nach
dem urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichts
gerne vorlesen wenn das gewünscht ist
die araber das nicht solange sich aber
anders als die csu an wir immer
vertreten dass man diese einnahmen
vollständig und zwar hoch kopf an die
bevölkerung zurück gibt das heißt dass
diejenigen die zum beispiel wenig
einkommen ein im verhältnis zu ihren
einkommen höheren zuschuss haben und zum
beispiel alleinerziehende familien mit
vielen kindern deutlich stärker
entlastet werden als
alleinstehende im prenzlauer berg
herr trittin aber nochmal wenn sie jetzt
auch in den verhandlungen über eine
pendlerpauschale sprechen fernseher
bereit
ich werde hier überhaupt nichts zu
irgendwelche verhandlungsdetails aber
tradition bei bild lei vertritt ihn ja
das weiß ich aber dass man andere
verhandlungen damals haben zwei oder
einmal anderthalb parteien am tisch
gesessen
die unter frau merkel nicht mehr
regieren wollte die eineinhalb
entschieden die partie von der scheuer
die ganz dagegen waren damals die fdp
wir sind heute in einer anderen
situation die cdu/csu ist erklärtermaßen
nicht regierungsfähig das ist nicht von
mir sondern aus den eigenen reihen und
dann haben wir drei parteien ist es
jetzt aber ablenkung sonst eben auch
ihren wie würdest du jamaika auch viel
einfallen
wir haben das heute fest der 1000 haben
direkt ein entlastungspaket miteinander
darüber und sie sprechen nicht mit der
künftigen opposition
[Musik]